bonjour jean marc jancovici
bonjour vous êtes spécialiste de la
transition énergétique s'est associé
fondateur du cabinet carbone 4 président
de the chief project manque du haut
conseil pour le climat alors dans une
interview précédente on parlait du
problème de la rareté à venir de toutes
les formes d'énergie et et de l'impact
que peut avoir sur l'activité économique
donc le double risque à la fois donc
climatique et économique et en même
temps vous dites la france a énormément
d'atouts pour s'adapter face à ce type
de contrainte pourquoi alors comme
l'énergie fossile a fondé la totalité du
développement industriel qui nous
entourent que c'est ça qui a permis
d'augmenter la productivité de
l'agriculture en donnant aux
agriculteurs des tracteurs des engrais
des phytosanitaires et donc ça m'a
permis de vider les campagnes puis de
mettre tout le monde dans les usines
puis dans les bureaux que c'est ça qui a
permis l'émergence des villes que c'est
ça qui a donné un moyen de transport
facile à utiliser à tout le monde qui
s'appelle une voiture et à ceux qui en
ont les moyens qui s'appelle l'avion que
c'est ça qui a permis d'avoir cent mille
produits disponibles pour pas cher dans
les magasins que c'est ça qui a permis
de construire des logements pour
quelques années de salaire alors que
c'était impensable il ya quelques
siècles
en fait ces trucs là ont fondé la
totalité du monde qui nous entoure
ça veut dire que d'arriver à s'en passer
c'est pardonnez moi l'expression après
maints des merdes abl c'est quelque
chose d'extrêmement compliqué alors je
vais prendre un langage d'ingénieurs
c'est un axe et ses teintes s'éteindre
un problème terriblement complexe
d'optimisation sous contrainte si vous
avez une grosse contrainte qui est que
ceux qui a infusé la civilisation
industrielle devient moins disponibles
contracte le parc de machines qui
fonctionnent et vous allez devoir tirer
le meilleur parti d'une situation dans
laquelle vous avez une contrainte
croissance c'est ça qu'on appelle
l'optimisation sous contrainte alors il
se trouve que la france par tradition
est depuis longtemps un pays
d'excellence quand il s'agit de trouver
des solutions d'optimisation sous
contrainte
le métier typique de l'optimisation sous
contrainte c'est l'ingénierie
l'ingéniérie c'est quand vous devez
tirer le meilleur parti de ce que vous
avez alors vous avez d ingénierie dans
le bâtiment vous avez d ingénierie dans
le pétrole d ingénierie dans le
nucléaire d'ingénierie dans le
ferroviaire d ingénierie dans la
téléphonie des injecteurs et quel que
soit le secteur dans lequel il faut
des ingénieurs pour concevoir des grands
systèmes complexes vous vous rendez
compte que la france a toujours brillé
toujours été sur les premières marches
du podium
nous avons en france un des meilleurs
systèmes hospitaliers au monde c'est un
truc très compliqué un système
hospitalier c'est un des meilleurs au
monde même si les français on se pète en
disant qu'il n'est pas terrible nous
avons un des meilleurs systèmes
ferroviaires au monde même si les
français rouspète en disant qu'il n'est
pas terrible nous avons encore pour le
moment un des meilleurs systèmes
électriques au monde même si les
français disent qu'il est pas terrible
et qu'il faudrait transformer nous avons
un des meilleurs nous avons formé les
meilleurs ingénieurs pétroliers technip
et schlumberger et qui sont deux grands
d'ingénierie mondiale afin de se faire
bouffer l'une et l'autre par les
américains ont été fondées par des
français la plus grosse ingénierie
ferroviaire romande et française
systra dans l'eau et dans les services
urbains
nous avons les deux plus gros un génial
est mondiale donc quand il s'agit de
faire des gros systèmes complexes à
large échelle
les français sont très bons et donc si
je rapproche sa du problème à traiter
qui est un monstrueux problèmes
d'optimisation sous contrainte
j'ai envie de dire fonds sont ces faits
pour nous c'est à dire qu'on va arriver
à penser comment utiliser le moins
d'énergie possible exactement c'est à
dire il faut penser la rareté pour
quelque chose qui offre le meilleur
bénéfice possible à la collectivité
par ailleurs quand je dis collectivités
il faut se rappeler que la france est le
seul pays communistes d'europe de
l'ouest donc chez nous la collectivité
est quelque chose qui conserve un sens
très important on est bien meilleur on
est on est bien mieux câble et plus
exactement sur ce plan là que les
américains que les anglais ou même
quelque part que les italiens ou les
allemands donc on a on a une capacité
aussi à concevoir le bénéfice collectif
au regard de quelque chose qu'on qu'on
pourrait faire il manque qu il manque
une politique qui les hissa il manque
deux choses la première c'est de compter
de se rappeler qu'on est dans une course
contre la montre et qu'on peut pas
attendre des siècles avant de s'y coller
parce que la course contre la montre
c'est l'épuisement décoller des
combustibles fossiles et c'est le
changement climatique par ailleurs comme
décarbonés l'économie c'est la
contracter parce que moins d'énergies
fossiles c'est moins de machines et donc
c'est moins de pib il y aura pas de
place pour tout le monde dans cette
histoire donc il ya une prime au premier
parti dont je pouvais dire parmi les
pays voulait je préfère que ce soit moi
france plutôt que les voisins
l'égoïsme d'égoïsme bien compris alors
ce qui manque dans cette histoire c'est
deux choses
il manque une classe politique qui
comprennent le problème à traiter donc
la jeune activiste greta thoune berg a
raison de dire nous on a fait notre
travail à la maison que les politiques
fassent le leur et donc il est urgent
qu'il prenne le temps prioritairement de
comprendre que le problème à traiter est
un problème auquel on n'échappera pas
qu'ils emportent tout le reste sur son
passage et donc il faut qu'ils
comprennent bien parce que tant qu'ils
comprennent pas le bien le problème ils
vont dilapider des milliards dans les
trucs qui servent à rien et vont pas
s'occuper de ceux qui servirait vraiment
à quelque chose et il est urgent de
comprendre aussi que dans une économie
qui va se contracter
il faut avoir un critère de tri qui soit
lisible à opposer à la population pour
dire ça je prends ça je prends pas ça je
prends ça je prends pas exactement comme
le temps qui n'est pas extensible
il faut que vous ayez un critères
lisibles pour dire à vos enfants sa wii
s'annonce à oui ça non parce qu'ils
peuvent pas tout faire en même temps
d'accord ils font leurs études vous avez
un critère lisible qui est vous n'allez
pas en soirée parce que sinon si la
journée c'est 40 heures et qu'on
pourrait faire une grasse mat tous les
jours ça marche très bien mais on peut
pas donc c'est non hélas le fait d'avoir
un projet de type conquête de la lune ou
victoire sur le nazisme qui sont des
deux grand sursaut récent qu'on peut
qu'on peut trouver dans dents au sein
des communautés humaines et bien ça a
permis de rassembler tous les gens dans
l'effort autour d'un objectif commun est
décarbonée l'économie si on sait en
faire la pédagogie c'est aussi quelque
chose qui permettra de rassembler dans
l'effort tout le monde autour d'un
projet commun et du coup de dire ça
c'est cohérent avec l'effort ça ça l'est
pas donc ça je prends ça je prends pas
donc ça rend service à l'état ça rend
service aux gens parce que ça leur donne
de l'espoir
sadi vers quoi on va ça rend service à
l'économie parce que ça nous renforce
sur nos points forts
donc en gros dans un monde qui va
devenir nécessairement un peu plus
hostiles pour moi c'est quand même le
meilleur pari à faire et ça rend service
à tout le monde
c'est le moment de faire cette
optimisation sous l'étreinte jean marc
jancovici merci pour votre éclairage